Lindsay Lohan reveals her relationship
status and whether she's ready for a
Mean Girls reboot I game for oil t eg
spoke with the 31 year old actress
during the Daily Mail holiday party in
NYC on Wednesday where she opened up
about the possibility of reprising the
role of Cady heron I am game for this
I'm here in New York so Tina Fey better
be hiding or I'm gonna find her
and Lorne Michaels I know where his desk
is what would Cady heron be up to right
now I'm thinking she's she's been living
in Africa and adopts her children very
Madonna stop trying to make fetch happen
it's not going to happen
lilo also got candid on a potential
life-size reboot with Tyra Banks bulky
but not enough maybe when I'm here I can
talk to her about it
Lohan dished on her current relationship
status I don't think anyone could even
be in a relationship with Meeks I'm
never there oh I have good friends and
good family and I'm happy with myself I
want to focus on what I what I really
feel I want to do right now and I think
that's important and talked whether she
has plans to move back to the States
I love living in New York but I do love
the serenity and peace that I
in the Middle East because there are no
cameras in Dubai and I can actually
focus on what I want to do in life and I
don't have to always be scrutinized
every second so I can have a private
life and and have a public life but when
I choose to it
[Music]
you
[Music]